[Musique]
bonjour à toute la planète
ici tu entames canada en direct de
montréal de la tempête montréalaise
oui belle journée première journée de
tempête ici à montréal notre invité
spécial aujourd'hui qui sera sur skype
lui se trouve à edmonton ils ont déjà
reçu au moins une grosse tempête et le
sol est couvert de neige depuis un mois
là bas
ici au canada 4000 kilomètres plus loin
c'était c'était le cas jusqu'à
maintenant à hauteur de la basse et le
canada aussi
ouais on assiste fuseaux horaires on
pourra redonner à d'autres ils sont en
avance sur nous
en âge mais on est en avance heureux en
temps c'est vrai ça va bien merci
beaucoup d'être venu cette semaine lui
merci et ben
je salue nos auditeurs sur internet est
notre invité ses murs ben et de la
section de la section suis tellement
tellement docteur de l'équipe de
l'équipe de l'équipe de la femme
[Rires]
et puis notre ami de la section de
l'équipe française et espagnole de radio
canada international paloma martinez
bonjour bonjour stéphane et puis on
marie claude simard est avec nous notre
webmestre du côté français d'ailleurs
notre autre webmestre maintenant du côté
de la halle équipes latino-américaines
il s'agit de leonardo gimeno bonjour
longeront le côté de l'autre régis elle
la bonne vieille régie son qu'on avait
dans les années 70 on a deux pierres qui
travaillent aujourd'hui
et puis on vous remercie infiniment mais
l'un d'eux c'est que j'occupe des la
technologie youtube
c'est vrai oui il ya quand même une un
pied dans la nouvelle technologie
sociale
quand même possibilité promotion ici
alors notre sujet de la semaine tout le
monde doit le deviner grâce à cette
vidéo 5 images on y va on regarde si
vous avez des choses à des informations
vous y allez vous n'hésitez pas première
image
non c'est pas lui c'est pas ça glisse
j'ai dit super héros bella dans ce sujet
c'est super héros installés mais c'est
passé spike lee we strongly troisième
image quel sujet cette semaine les
suppressions annoncées par valérie
plantes qui 4ème image qu'elle est sujet
cette semaine mais encore plus précis
quand même 31 salon du livre de bande
dessinée
sa maman que le capitaine pour madame
kanev s'est dissout la voici maintenant
la réponse apprentis de france à
marie-claude sur la bonne piste et
capitaine porto rico ah oui là la bande
des cinq africable medicare et comme
seule étoile face à des bandes dessinées
tricolore n'a pas vu le capitaine canu
qu on pourrait le voir celui ci vous
invite à déjà fait une recherche sur le
web pour nous montrer le 4 août en cas
nuque
parce qu'on ne sait pas de quoi on parle
ça met en image soit plus nos propos on
est tous sur le web ou celui en profiter
on dessine c'était super héros canadiens
mais ce qu'ils pensent être capitaine
kirk nom du personnage très important de
la science fiction qui est décédé cette
semaine il ya pas beaucoup de gens qui a
parlé de lui mais s'appelle douglas
c'est la voix qui a fait les 9000 ou
dans la 2001 odyssée dans l'espace il
n'y a pas de problème
l'amour support dvd ça fait c'était ma
pas à moitié
vous aussi au générique de fin jusqu'où
la force de ce film là c'est qu'il va
pas d'effets spéciaux extraordinaire ou
bien oui mais c'est peut-être ça l'aise
c'est ça qu'elle n'avait pas peut-être
ne voyez pas il n'y a pas de musique
avec le silence et deux personnages et
l'interaction et voilà tout cas côté
voilà le capitaine canada pour parler
l'anglais jeu de la grosse boule avant
dernière notre invité parce que nos
points on les accumule et il faut bien
aussi que les dépenses et en annonçant
pour vous cette semaine nous enlève deux
points avant de gagner les points
les règles du jeu ont changé
la bonne nouvelle c'est même qui touche
ap
alors vous avez tous sens fois chacun
aujourd'hui c'est merveilleux non ça
changerait strip tease voici premier jeu
de la grosse boule la bd plus populaire
que jamais vous êtes d'accord avec
l'affirmation henry
je ne sais pas je le vois je suis allé
au salon du livre
il y avait un engouement commun pour
former un char il y avait 1 60% de bd
pour moi c est qu on choisit alors aussi
la question après l'affirmation voici la
question de la francophonie combien de
nouvelles bd sont mises en marché dans
le monde chaque année
je vais vous aider d'accord vous aide
parce que je m'aperçois qu'il faut
absolument à vous aider
[Rires]
alors combien de nouvelles bd sont mises
en marché dans le monde chaque année à
500 nouvelles bdb
mais une nouvelle bd en france et chaque
année c'est mes 500 nouvelles bd chaque
année en français ou des 5000 nouvelles
bd en français jamais bah oui parce que
ça dépend à quel niveau mais si on pense
à toutes les jeunes aiment au niveau de
l'école où 1500 1505 gérer pour cinq
mille 5000 bbc africa leur chance en
main aux rebelles se seraient mis le
bingo non alors la bonne réponse c'est
soit c ou d soit cod vous vous
sélectionnez quoi c ou d elle a gagné sa
mue ici on a gagné
puis c est monté moitié ok alors qu'il a
répondu c'est jeudi 5 mai n'hésitez pas
qui est le crédit s'est levé la main
vous perdez chacun un point j'adore
règlement ya même des reportages avant
de dessiner maintenant oui oui oui
c'était l'an dernier c'est exactement
mon job oui et même une version en arabe
aussi connerie c'est pour ça que l'on va
on va les voir ça un petit peu plus tard
émission hockey parce que donner une
idée c'est une bonne idée
on va les verts l'invité de la semaine
pourquoi pas alors vraiment c'est je
pense un des spécialistes dans le monde
de la bd francophone y avait pas les
petites écouter toute personne
compétente et ongles
vous le savez très bien alors il s'agit
de chris prent chikhou ba qui est né à
charleroi en belgique qu'il a grandi
dans le quartier des éditions dupuis
depuis ou du puiur oui depuis combien
d'années d'ailleurs monsieur crise il y
a beaucoup d'années notre jeu et il
travaille maintenant à l'université de
l'alberta comme associé professeurs et
se spécialise dans la bande dessinée une
enseigne en fait un des cours unique au
pays sur les comics donc les super héros
et les graphiques sont nos gosses en
anglais et découvre sur la bd en
français merci d'avoir accepté
l'invitation cette semaine de vous
joindre à nous
avec didier merci j'avais joué à la mer
quand même j'avais contacté quelqu'un un
spécialiste choisissant spécialiste de
la bd à montréal pour me faire dire que
il voulait pas parler de spike lee ou
[Rires]
sepa bruce il est en tout cas ne pas
parler de cet homme parce qu'il
considère son héritage pour la bande
dessinée était en fait négatifs
je vous demande notamment de gérer avec
une une opinion aussi plombé mais vous
qui êtes un spécialiste comment vous
voyez l'oeuvre de cet homme qui a été un
génie au plan du marketing de la bande
dessinée non c'est exactement ça en fait
disons qu'il ya deux choses chez lui
qu'on doit revenir la première c'est
qu'il a vraiment créé une série de
super-héros
c'est sans doute dans la centaine mais
une dizaine super connus comme hulk se
parer de men iron men qui sont des
personnages bons qui sont présents dans
le monde entier est littéralement à
travers d'abord les bandes dessinées
dans les années 60
et puis
vers tous les médias et justement ça
sert deuxième partie de sa carrière à la
limite
après soixante quinze 75 en français
correct
c'est ce qu'il va faire c'est promouvoir
ses propres produits à travers les
différents médias d'avoir la télévision
et puis les films mais dans les années
2000 l'explosion de marvel était héros
de marvel quand ça va être racheté par
disney aujourd'hui on a plus
l'impression que c'est un incontournable
moi qui adore il fait même avec des
effets spéciaux
j'adore les films avec des vraies
histoires aussi la fait pas mais dans un
tas canton un peu paresseux on aime bien
regarder ça mais pas pour accuser ceux
qui regardent ça qu'ils sont paresseux
alors c'est ça alors faut faire
attention à ce qu'on dit alors je vous
les voulez signer depuis vingt et un ans
j'ai l'impression qu'un véritable
explosion
si un film est populaire il a du succès
au box office c'est parce qu'il ya des
bonnes chances que ce soit un film avec
des super héros dedans c'est devenu une
recette on dirait oui c'est un peu vrai
en même temps une fois les recettes
c'est des recettes intéressant du
libellé des recettes en cuisine qui sont
quand on les respecte bien qu'ils sont
délicieuses veut dire donc il n'ya pas
de raison pour rejeter la recette en
elle-même je veux dire donc parfois
évidemment il y en a d'ailleurs qui ont
échoué en fait en utilisant les mêmes
recettes aux différentes raisons qui
sont souvent difficiles à déterminer
d'ailleurs il y en a qui ont échoué mais
c'est vrai que il ya une nord-est est
maintenant le super oc au cinéma quelque
chose qui marche très bien et ce qui est
intéressant justement c'est que les
super héros au cinéma avait été
anticipée dès les années façon comme on
disait même avant avec la première vague
de dc qui avait été anticipé par les
bandes dessinées qui était capable de
faire
sur le papier ce que les effets spéciaux
ce que le cinéma à l'époque dans les
années 40-50 15 ans ne pouvait pas faire
et donc à partir du moment où les effets
spéciaux sont tellement élaboré comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui où ils sont
capables de le faire
le cinéma prendre un peu la relève dans
le domaine des super héros ce qui est
très différent dans la bande dessinée
sur les romans graphiques ou la bande
dessinée francophone ou au contraire
elle se dirige vers quelque chose qu'il
le contraire des cdd et cdi
samir est nécessairement américain on
north america et ce qui pourrait pas
être ouais ça c'est une très bonne
question est oui de manière très
évidente c'est quelque chose qui est
[Musique]
absolu juger c'est assez incroyable
super héros c'est américain ray il ya un
parallèle extraordinaire à faire entre
la superpuissance américaine qui
commence à bon dans les années 30
évidemment il ya le cas pas une date
précise mais et le sup le premier
super-héros donc superman ne rend tout
nu et 138 et qui lance le super héros
sur le marché qui devient assez vite
international et ample parallèle des
états unis qui interviennent dans la
deuxième guerre mondiale et qui est à
part qu'à ce moment là deviennent la
superpuissance et qui progressivement va
battre après une longue guerre froide
l'urss et devenir la seule puisse
superpuissance dans le monde donc un
parallèle évident entre le monopole
qu'ont les états unis sur le super héros
et le monopole que les états unis ou
dans le domaine dans le monde réel
en fait dans le monde réel moi j'ai une
question concernant les femmes d'aller
dans le contexte des super-héros
d'anglais super héroïne
pourquoi il ya si peu des super héroïne
vous diriez non tout à fait ça
ça reflète encore une fois je te montre
tout comme la le super-héros reflète la
superpuissance américaine même si c'est
de manière déformée évidemment si jamais
un reflet direct mais c'est la même
chose pour l'absence quasi absence de
super héroïne jusqu'à il ya dix ans
parce qu'on vit dans un système
patriarcal parce que c'est un système
totalement dominé par des hommes et
spécialement des hommes blancs jusqu'à
il ya 20 ans tout le système
hollywoodien l'était aussi
avec une particularité c'est que en fait
la majorité des super héros ont été
créées par des
des zones d'origine juive de culture
juive
et ça c'est un phénomène extrêmement
intéressant aussi c'est que comment dire
évidemment on ne les connaît pas comme
ça en général sauf récemment mais au
début en tout cas simplement parce
qu'ils se cachent en fait stan lee
c'était une personne d'origine juive
dont je sais ses parents avaient immigré
vers les etats unis vers niort et il a
très vite pour justement cacher son
identité et son identité de suivi il
change de nom et devient donc ses
psaumes origines originale ses leaders
libre lee burke et puis il devient lit
simplement pour cacher ses origines du
mal
mais c'est à peu près la même chose avec
les dix ans l'aigle mais les races en
fait c'était tout un coup spectaculaire
black panther des films qu'il ya plus
des gens qui est allé les voir
c'était la première fois qu'ils en
avaient vraiment légitime et un noir
dans lé rôle d'un super héros qui la
culture noire africaine de surcroît dans
ce cas si oui et ça aussi c'est la même
chose que pour les femmes donc en fait
la première femme intervient en fait
assez tôt c'est en 1941 c'est à dire un
peu plus de deux ans après le lancement
de superman et mais elle va être unique
elle va être quasiment la seule il y en
a d'autres mais qui sont très peu connus
sont aujourd'hui tombés dans les années
20 aux années 60 qui commence en avoir
d'autres qui sont toujours en général
sexualisé présenté comme objet sexuel
d'une manière ou d'une autre ou de
simples caractère qui permettra et qui
permettent à l'homme aux super héros
même d'être plus encore
et puis c'est seulement à partir des
années 2000 qu'interviennent des
mauvaises super héroïnes ont fait le
train fait dans l'histoire je vu un film
qui raconte l'histoire de la v wonder
woman
c'était vraiment un personnage qui fait
c'est comme un réaction à la société
machiste c'était vraiment quelque chose
de très puissant
puis après il a changé bison baisser le
ton ils ont changé le l'ont fait comme
une héroïne en tant que tel mais un
premier recours c'était vraiment une
réaction féministe une des premières
donc tout à fait le créateur en fait
deux comment dire de wonder woman est un
personnage tout à fait ambiguë est tout
à fait intéressant parce que c'est un
homme d'abord un homme blanc ce qui ce
qui constituait une exception à l'époque
comme j'ai dis parce que la majorité à
tous mais une bonne majorité plus de 50
% des créateurs et des mondes ailleurs
et les gens qui appartenait à ce monde
des comics en fait les prod les
producteurs par exemple les éditeurs
étaient souvent aussi d'origine juive
pour différentes raisons et entre eux
parce qu'ils pouvaient pas trouver le
job dans d'autres domaines qui étaient
considérés plus sérieux par exemple
facteur puisque il était d'origine juive
on les accepte et pas dans l'édition
standard par exemple d'eau qu'il devait
créer leur propre maison d'édition dans
des domaines que les autres lester pour
eux s'ils voulaient le rejet constant
qui réduisait donc ça pouvait le faire
si vous voulez en pensant qu'ils ne le
feraient pas d'argent ou que c'était pas
ça n'allait pas faire beaucoup d'argent
alors que après ça va devenir
extrêmement populaire au début on a eu
on a eu le patriarcat blanc si on veut
dire maintenant on est passé un peu à
des héroïnes et à des indes et même d un
héros de couleurs comme black panther
mais dites-moi est-ce que ça c'est de la
correction politique ou bien s'est il ya
des enjeux économiques rossi est ce que
les gens qui quand ils choisissent sais
quoi qui les motive chinois et c'est une
très bonne question il ya une dynamique
entre les deux mais il est évident que
le facteur économique est un facteur
essentiel dans la mesure où on le voit
la diversité aux états unis devient un
fait même électorale la dernière
élection l'a montré encore une fois
contre la grosse machine trump du
mensonge strub et de tout ce que ça
implique où les minorités arrive quand
même malgré toute la machinerie qui est
contre eux si on veut contre donc c'est
une vraie démocratie
démocratie multiculturelle diversité
diversité il y a donc un facteur
économique essentiel en même temps il ya
aussi le fait que la société ce
multiculturalisme y compris dans les
minorités
enfin je veux dire dans l'ancien bastion
du loyer ou beaucoup d'eau à son change
aussi tir et accepte de plus en plus
comment dire cette diversité donc cédé
deux facteurs plus jour je voulais faire
une mise en garde ici le sujet des
missions ce ne sont pas les héros
américains ou kryptonien justement pour
la bande dessinée française en fait il
ya quasiment pas de dans la bande
dessinée française de super héros gérer
la 2e qui sont connus sur astérix et ça
va faire nécessairement rigoler parce
que oui ça les salles et par certains
côtés ou de manier rôle évident et on
n'est pas quoi et alors il ya super du
pauvre sais pas si vous connaissez il
est peut-être moins connus au québec
comment il a perdu pas super plus perdu
une parodie c'est une parodie de
superman c'est une parodie très subtil
en france très connu c'est un personnage
très connu mais uniquement en france
parce qu'il équipait en libye tout en
français il les représente une parodie
une satire un peu de comment dire de de
la france profonde entre guillemets
c'est à dire une france franchouillard
abord un peu marsupilami aussi et c'est
des francophones qu'ils ont lu et
valérian ses milices et des super héros
tout ça on dira pas que tintin super
héros même s'il est né un peu avant et
parallèlement a justement à superman et
aux super héros
et justement il n'est pas un super héros
et c'est intéressant parce que c'est un
produit 2,2 comment dire de la nation
belge à l'époque est encore une nation
importante à l'époque en 1930
économiquement politiquement et elle
produit donc un héros qui est un héros
extraordinaire qui arriva
dans le monde entier pour sauver des tas
de gens donc un peu comme le super héros
mais il n'a pas du tout les capacités du
super héros et trésor il n'a pas de
super puissant sun jeu super pouvoirs
qui est une des premières
caractéristiques du super héros aussi on
veut comme scénario quand même
il est super intelligent même s'il est
pas super puissant moi je m'approche
c'est plus facile d'apprendre d'avoir de
tirer des leçons quand on entend un
enfant moi c'était un modèle gt en
afrique avait rien à lire c'était
ennuyant on avait les tintin on avait
les valérian on avait les spirous
c'était la gaffe pour savoir comment se
comporter au travail dans l'avenir c'est
des modèles et je viens de rentrer si
les super héros américains sont autant
des modèles pour les enfants que nos
noms super-héros francophone il ya
quelque chose je pense ici de très
intime dans la relation que moi j'ai
développée qu'on a développée avec des
tintin avec des astérix beaucoup plus
qu'avec des superman me semble oui je
mettrai une première mise en garde c'est
le danger de deux mètres la bande
dessinée parce que vous venez de lire
dans le domaine des enfants alors c'est
à dire c'est vrai que la bande et je
suis désolé d'apprendre dessinée c'est
aussi pour enfants elle est d'abord par
exemple superman en 1938 le le public
visé c'est d'abord les enfants
mais très vite ça va devenir des
adolescents puis des jeunes adultes et
c'est la même chose un peu pour tintin
des adultes et donc dans les années 60
une des particularités de stan lee pour
revenir à lui parce que c'était en
partie à propos de district ou du bar
établi en fait sa particularité c'est
justement d'avoir créé des super héros
qui sont des jeunes adultes et
adolescents voire des jeunes adultes ils
ont qui sait 18 ans voire donc des
adultes complet comme par exemple et qui
justement connaître connaissent des
doutes millions qui sont des super héros
qui ne sont plus des supérieurs aux
antilles comme superman qui n'ont pas de
problèmes qui sont qui ont tous les
supers pouvoirs qui vont toujours gagné
donc ça va devenir des personnages qui
ont eu à une existence humaine et qui se
rapproche d'un d'un personnage comme
beaucoup de romans trier un peu ma
question serait ou
si concernant le biais d'un sens ou
qu'est-ce que le type de bande dessinée
francophone ont fait aujourd'hui ce
qu'est ce qui se produit actuellement ce
qui concerne la bande dessinée
francophone alors c'est très divers il
ya vraiment c'est un peu ça toujours été
assez divers mais maintenant c'est
vraiment une explosion non seulement en
quantité en nombre de deux nouvelles
publications comme on l'a vu 5000 le
sait absolument extraordinaire 5 me par
an mais c'était aussi une grande
diversité dans cette danse et 5000
nouvelles publications il ya des albums
évidemment pour enfants strictement pour
enfants il y en a pour la famille comme
avant comme ce qui est le cas de spirou
comme c'était le cas de tintin mais il
ya aussi une série d'albums reportage
par exemple extrêmement sérieuse sur
l'immigration sur sur les comment dire
sur l'afrique enfin sur sur le y compris
au québec donc il ya aussi une grande
diversité au québec il ya une bd
d'avant-garde par exemple donc
expérimental qui cherche à jouer avec
les normes de la bande dessinée donc un
peu maintenant on en arrive un peu à ce
que les mangas avons toujours été ou en
tout cas depuis les années 60
de plus beaucoup plus longtemps c'est à
dire que ça touche tous les publics
fille garçon les bleus ensemble de ses
parts et adultes enfants séparés ou
ensemble et tous les sujets possibles
vraiment littéralement tous les sujets
possibles
mais ce qui a le plus de femmes qui
écrivent qu'ils qui font des bandes
dessinées pour quelqu'un raconte leur
histoire
oui ça c'est encore une bonne question
aussi parce que il ya le nombre a grandi
mais ça reste quand même toujours très
modeste et ça reste donc toujours un
problème
on en était en il ya eu un scandale en
2012 2016 pardon au festival d'angoulême
à cause de ça parce que il avait nominé
je pense c'était une trentaine d'hommes
seulement il n'y avait pas et donc à une
révolte des gens y compris de certains
hommes en disant absolument aberrant et
donc ça c'est un facteur qui m'ont très
bien qu'il ya un réel problème et ont
compté qu'en 2012 il y avait 12 % à peu
près de femmes dans le monde de la bande
dessinée sais pas pourquoi
ah non c'était vraiment pas beaucoup du
tout nouveau saab ont monté un petit peu
on en est peut-être un an à 1 16% mais
on est encore loin
il y en a beaucoup surtout dans le
domaine expérimental par exemple ou non
le domaine alternatif
ils ont déjà comment dire de
l'autobiographie par exemple mais risqué
a aussi il ya augmenté la quantité des
personnages femmes dans les bandes
dessinées aujourd'hui oui mais ça
évidemment ça pose toujours un problème
dans la mesure où les ca augmenter à
plus de femmes
en fait dès les années 70 on voit plus
de femmes dans valérian part annoncé un
cas intéressant tu cites et valerio tout
à l'heure et valérian c'est intéressant
parce que s'est créée par deux hommes
dans les années 70 et il y a le titre de
la bande dessinée c'est valerio est en
fait c'est seulement en 2005 ou 2006 si
on m'appelle bien que la bande dessinée
on trouve un nouveau titre qui intègre
la femme qui est aussi importante que
valerio maintenant je recherche sur le
web
laureline voilà l'origine j'ai trouvé
leur ligne donc c'est valérian et
laureline b pendant quarante ans cette
histoire a porté le titre uniquement de
l'homme alors que dans l' aventure ce
qui était intéressant justement dans
cette aventure c'est que l'homme et la
femme étaient plus ou moins égalité zéro
c'est une très belle relation c'est ce
que j'aimais beaucoup
ils s'entraident est l'un l'autre
c'était très agréable
il y avait une aventure à new york qui
était sous l'eau afin qu'ils étaient
inondées le dessin est extraordinaire
mais le texte aussi l'histoire était
irréprochable
une dernière question restera la bd
francophone est une bd francophonie à
une bd française suisses belges que les
quoi québécois est ce que parce que
c'est quoi qui l'est ce qui les
différencie un peu on va pas faire une
longue histoire mais juste on pourrait
plus dire qu'il ya une bande dessinée
suisse ou belge
en fait il ya une bd francophone marié
ya peut-être certaines particularités
québécoise un peu plus isolé au pour
être hué surplus caractéristiques
peut-être parce que sans doute
l'isolation là
la distance d'une part le fait qu'il ya
une influence américaine plus forte
peut-être il ya certains facteurs qu'on
pourrait analyser comme ça mais non on
peut pas vraiment parler de banc d'essai
française
c'est d'abord parce que la dominant il
ya eu un facteur belge est extrêmement
important dès le début des années 30 40
50 et donc on a comparé en général
d'ailleurs de tradition franco-belge en
fait n'est pas par armand de la bd
française de la tradition franco belge
mais qui devrait intégrer quelques
exemples importants de la suisse par
exemple titeuf qui était un personnage
extrêmement populaire qu'ils ont par
million d'exemplaires en france il en
francophonie est en fait d'origine
suisse par exemple
et qu'est ce qui se vend le mieux du
côté du québec à l'extérieur des
frontières de cette province
par exemple cette en alberta ce que vous
voyez il ya de la bande dessinée
québécoise alors l'alberta s'est quand
même hein c'est bon comme vous le savez
ces anglophones à 99%
d'ailleurs même les comics c'est pas ça
ne domine pas ici loin de la jante
justement de faire une carte pour ma
patte onglet pour notre cartographie un
peu l'histoire des comics dans edmonton
et dans l'alberta mais c'est aussi quand
on fait ça on se rend compte qu en a
beaucoup mais en même temps
proportionnellement c'est rien du tout
en fait très bien cotés et s'il faut
vous laisser aller il faut que vous
puissiez compléter votre album vous même
vous êtes en train de vous faites pas de
bande dessinée vous n'êtes pas
dessinateur pâte à d'autres n'ont pas
non traite quand j'aurais le temps oui
oui alors que l'essence chez koba merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté l'invitation et
ça me permet à beaucoup de gens de vous
découvrir je suis sûr que lorsque des
proches un dossier sur la bande dessinée
ils vont frapper à la porte parce que
nous on vous a découvert grâce à un
collègue de chf à en alberta la radio de
radio-canada là-bas michel charron donc
on l'en remercie par part dans la vie du
web
merci à vous tous merci d'un grand
réseau
tendues les ailes on a pu savoir qu'il
existait on a pris connaissance de ce
qu'il avait à dire il est extrait je
vais être mentionné quelque chose
concernant monsieur coué monsieur reigns
parce qu'il a gardé le nom de famille de
sa femme aussi dans chic ou main c'est
lé nom de sa femme s'appelle crise voilà
l'or s'était fait mal acquis qui prend
carrément le nom de sa femme là à
propriano martinez par ce serait pas
très bonne écoute et on a le choix on
peut aller soit vers le deuxième jeu de
la grosse boule pour perdre davantage de
peine alors pour vous aider
non seulement on a là la grosse boule
oui on a aussi la vidéo pour appuyer la
question mais avant de rouler la faire
rouler de la vidéo à noter que je vois
je devais faire des choses j'ai eu des
lunettes ici pour vous annoncer ça je
pourrai rien à voir avec des lunettes
sur trois points de moins
c'est ce qui est en jeu 30 points de
moins alors qui a 100 points toujours
vous deux vous avez 80 chacun dont tant
de points à perdre maintenant j'adore
c'est adopter c'est vraiment beau temps
alors bossi lequel de ces festivals est
le plus grand festival francophone de la
bd dans le monde
notre invité à parler de l'un d'eux si
le choix parce qu'il faut vous aider
c'est bien sûr c'est bien connu
alors voici lequel de c est ce que c'est
ça le festival de bd de montréal dont
voici une affiche promotionnelle en 2016
est-ce que c'est plutôt b qui s'en vient
les stands le festival international de
la bande dessinée d'angoulême
ça c'est une affiche je sais pas si
c'est l'an dernier ou en 2018
ou est ce que c'est c'est le festival
mondial de la bd de paris ah oui à paris
à donald duck qui se promenaient au
est-ce que cds que cdd vraiment un choix
intéressant aucune de ces réponses
alors voici je répète la sélection
le festival de bd de montréal b le
festival international de la bande
dessinée d'angoulême dont on répète les
images ici est ce que c'est c'est le
festival mondial de la bd de paris ou
encore aucune de celles apportées je
veux je leur ai écouté l'énoncé d'une
référence dans vraiment séduit
lequel de ces festivals est le plus
grand festival francophone de la bd dans
le monde
ok moi gérer pour angoulême angoulême
parce que j'en entends parler tout le
temps j'aime sa part des points à la
république
là vous amuser je payer pour ça vous le
savez bien
lequel de ces festivals est le plus
grand festival de francophones de la bd
dans le monde écoute g boudry angoulême
ça le festival international de la bd de
la bande dessinée d'angoulême beauty
paris que ses conclusions
alors j'espère que certains d'entre vous
être prêt à perdre des points
je suis prête vous allez me dire où se
trouve le festival d'angoulême angoulême
où se trouve angoulême
j'étais encore en classe primaire ou
quoi le festival d'angoulême c'est en
france elle face aux halles de paris ça
n'existe pas j'ai mis une fausse photo
qui venait du festival de luzerne de la
bande dessinée du cern sa substance usa
junte civile c'est un ps n'a pas de
réponses si festival d'angoulême qui a
bien attendu
alors alors c'est plus tranquille
alors on en est alors on fait une
récapitulation au niveau des points
passé difficile à suivre votre histoire
5 1 500 105,50 très bien donc 2 50 et 2
cents on a raté je sais pas encore ce
que la prochaine question vous pouvez
perdre 500 ou
on peut maintenant mais je voulais vous
faire plaisir
paloma qui a mentionné le fait qu'ils
n'avaient pas beaucoup de femmes qui
étaient auteurs de bandes dessinées et
auteur avec et on va les allées les
vidéos numéro 4 avant de la passer avant
de la diffuser sur le web
je vois si j'ai offert je vous offre ce
si on a vu ça au réseau de radio canada
télévision cette semaine
vous étiez occupé à autre chose alors
vous n'avez pas vu et l'a 13 ans avant
de partir aux jo explique d'accord elle
a 13 ans seulement s'appelle laura
bourbeau c'est bien avec un nom comme ça
à faire de la bd elle fait simplement
partie de la relève de la bande dessinée
au québec
elle a déjà publié un livre et c'est
elle même qui a fait les démarches
auprès des maisons d'édition alors c'est
une des cinq mille bande dessinée comme
ça cette année francophones et voici un
portrait est effectuée par le
journaliste ou la journaliste dominique
landry on écoute ça dure pas longtemps
c'est un extrait du reportage une munich
a du sens
je suis allé sur l'esm d'affaires
j'arrive avec un petit peu mais à
l'époque la principale raison pourquoi
j'ai écrit la turquie on en voit il y en
a beaucoup dans les écoles et c'est
important d'en parler il ne peut pas
arrêter vraiment très inspiré mais j'ai
tout de suite commencé à écrire mon
livre
et puis le j'écrive à des intervalles
report prêts réguliers parce que c'était
juste pour le plaisir
donc ça m'a pris un an l'écrire au
complet puis ensuite j'ai fait les
démarches pour le publier
je les fais moi même la une après midi
jeux d'ester 2 j'en avais parlé à mes
parents en mal mais j'ai cherché des
maisons d'édition jeunesse puis je leur
ai envoyé mon manuscrit et puis c'est la
maison d'édition harper qui a décidé de
télé publiés c'est une maison d'édition
à risque partagé donc qu en payer une
partie mais nous aussi donc on a fait
une page facebook avait pour refaire
sociaux financement
donc on a pré vente des livres puis
c'est comme ça qu'est on a financé notre
projet maintenant mon lycée ml c'est
long de la personnage principal elle est
en 6e année et elle se fait éliminer par
une fille qui s'appelle patricia donc
elle ne donne pas le nom votre âge en
free puis me lit elle est un peu gênée
elle dit parce qu'elles pensent elle
veut pas trop se faire remarquer donc
elle va devoir travailler ce prix avoir
plus confiance en elle puis l'a10 nation
de la bonne façon
alors intimidations moi je me sens
intimidée par autant de talent un ca son
histoire de montage financier
elle est très conscient en même temps il
a un grain de pureté dix ans dans sa
façon de parler donc cesser ce qui est
cantonné au times équipe comme ça que ça
marche active
vous parlez de vous cherchez à la relève
très récemment il ya eu le festival de
la bande dessinée d'alger
au mois de septembre et le mois
d'octobre où il ya eu huit auteurs
québécois qui étaient présents il y
avait à parité en fonction il y avait un
peu plus de femmes que d'hommes
je me demandais pas les noms mais il ya
eu la vie vous fait un reportage là
dessus j'ai fait l'annoncé de
l'événement du premier jour comme ça
j'en ai fait en europe si vous voulez je
peux vous traduis les pas de points
est-ce que vous c'est sur le web
oui c'est sur le web on peut il faut
chercher très touchante elle trouver un
il est bon pour moi je sais comment
trouver mais si comme si vous voulez on
peu morte ça va être l'enjeu parce que
ça on vous donnait un cours vous pouvez
cliquer pour elle c'était mais c'est en
arabe je pense qu'on comprendra pas un
[Rires]
[Musique]
petit bijou qu'est ce qui va y avoir une
autre question
oui mais ça que mes collègues verts
écoute les histoires de vente dessinée
c'est et puis des super d2 c'est à peu
près la même chose je me rappelle il ya
une seule ça fait longtemps que je
l'avais vue d
une seul film cet espagnol ou l'antique
liste est arrivée à madrid
j'étais un curé de madrid une gueule
travail dans une vidéo porno puis une
une autre passante qui lui était laissé
ses trois passions qui luttait contre
l'anti christ qui est un lieu d tombés à
new york il y avait arrivé alors c'est
toujours compte dans ses autres aux
etats unis les super d2 puis toutes les
choses qui passent dans le monde cela ça
c'est le sport canadien du festival de
la bande dessinée à alger ça s'est passé
juste pour revenir
c'était au mois est ce que tu peux
descendre un peu marre et que ça s'est
passé
plus haut plus haut pour voir juste la
date c'était le début octobre 2010 huit
ans que c'est ça et puis on a la liste
des sa cellule en allonge du festival ça
c'est le mouvement sadriste canadiennes
qui ont eu la photo parce que c'est elle
qui a ouvert le festival parce que celle
là cette année le canada était le pays à
l'honneur
donc c'est pour ça qu'il a eue le oui
c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu les trois les
huit heures auteurs québécois
je sais ça donc c'est qu'ils ont
participé mais je sais que même temps il
ya des québécois qui s'apparent dont les
bédéistes québécois qui ont participé
bon ça finit donc ça peut être aussi sur
la page web de l'émission l'a nommé lyon
c'est pas mon meilleur coup ça s'appelle
chercher dans les archives de
radio-canada international s'est relié
au sujet de l'émission aujourd'hui et on
a quelque chose sur rêve pas d'un oui
ah oui on a fait l'émission spéciale je
me souviens très bien
17 octobre 2017 ils s'affairaient jeudi
7 octobre texte le 15 mai voici les
mésaventures de rêve pas de wii en pays
de au pays de l'or noir c'était une
boutique démission soit ils ont
l'imagination les bédéistes est rien
voilà oui oui d'autres histoires sur
stanley donc on a regroupé et même de la
pub de la bande dessinée où il ya un
petit problème 6 ans
de la bd politique
on a tous eu à vous proposez vous pour
aller voir ça mais on est prêt pour le
jeu de la grosse boule parce que malgré
génial c'est vraiment vous qui dicte et
l'émission aujourd'hui un mais je
il faut que je garde mes 50 50 points
est dernière question troisième question
vidéo b oui si tu absolument merci
d'avoir réveillé un peu
alors est ce que c'est un des noms c'est
la réponse qu'on peut pas représenter
cela répond d'abord la question
à l'école je sais qu'ils donnent des
réponses en madih question mais alors on
y va
dernière question depuis l'antiquité
l'homme cherche à classer et à
classifier les arts jose a ajouté les
femmes les hommes
merci cher chaque la csu mais quand j'ai
écrit ça quand même qualifié classifier
les uns ont cherché à classifier qu'on
soit homme ou femme on veut classifiés
on parle tantôt de l' architecture comme
du premier rares ou de la sculpture
comme étant le deuxième arts où se situe
la bande dessinée encore attendez un peu
vous avez des choix ça prend du temps à
organiser tout ça voici vos choix la
bande dessinée est considéré comme étant
le 5e arr la bande et ça c à b la bande
dessinée est le septième art notamment
des gens qui ont des tickets ici
cultiver la bande dessinée le neuvième
art in out et aucune de ces réponses ne
démarre
j'avais vraiment le goût de la vie aime
aussi ouais ouais mais je peux dire 8e
oui tu as gagné tu répètes cook
ouais je vais agir avec l'addition de
ces réponses des hoquets aucune de ces
réponses des 50 points à perdre
paloma gérer votre réponse réponse
réponse être 9e à 9e à un événement qui
a répondu nos vieillards
nous venons vous gardez vos points
[Rires]
quel est le score final vous ne vous
levez la main vous dites que c'est votre
corps sans grand gagnant se serait fait
des caisses et des caisses de super
héros américains à la maison ça fait au
moins vingt ans que je lis plus à moi je
vais sur le web regarder ça puis j'avais
à l'époque beaucoup de bandes dessinées
françaises tous les albums de spirou de
tintin évidemment thème j'ai dû racheter
parce que les choses ont disparu chez
moi comment ça se passe dans la vie des
enfants
gardez votre collection
non je tiens depuis maintenant je suis à
vos chères ce super comics américains
parce que oui parce que ya fait une
donation à la bibliothèque du québec
nationale vous habitez pas québec non je
vais t'en jeunes enfants aînés nous le
porter aux éditions dupuis depuis
écoutez je vais enfin je mange avec des
boîtes 250 minimum de recyclage c'est
justement sur kaboul camionneurs qui
vient chercher les ordures serait pas
content a beaucoup trop alors c'est tout
là il a gagné samedi merci pour ça sans
moi ça il a gardé ses points on garde de
votre je sais pas si je peux gagner qu'à
perdre oui oui il ya beaucoup de noms
mais ce n'est pas l'histoire départ il
faut que tu m'as ne tienne j'aime bien
la forme mes filles il ya deux trois
classes qui font ça ils commencent à
venise en concert il faut maintenir les
seins proscrit c'est pervers mais c'est
bon ça ça ne vient pas du tout
le gagnant est vraiment gagnant dans ce
cas là parce que il a la bonne chose ce
qu'est à la fin et on gagne 1 puis les
gens qui ont peut-être quelques points
oui comme formule tout le monde il y
avait déjà quelques zéros la fin
d'émission la ba oui parce que tu
commences par an voilà donc être tout le
monde sait très peu de garder non mais
tout aussi tout perdre monté par exemple
c'est un peu triste
en tout cas une émission à semaine
prochaine et sur les mathématiques est
donc identique
l'histoire ceux qui mentent et l'âge on
veut pas augmenter le poids
on veut pas augmenter les choses
allaient peut-être les salaires oui mais
je ne vais pas les augmenter mais en
augmentant les points je vous aime ça on
va pas on va dire qu'on va lire des
tweets des psychologies pouvoir qu'est
ce qui nous ferait plus place et perd
gagne
je pense qu'aujourd'hui j'ai gagné parce
qu'il y avait une très bonne odeur de
ton café et être sûr que oui c'était
très bon la semaine prochaine on
continue avec le règlement paloma genève
merci aux élus quelle planète fin aussi
laquelle merkel quelle caméra celle là
en semaine prochaine à la semaine
prochaine merci stéphane mercier
l'équipe